a triumph Angela Merkel has won the
biggest election victory of her
political career
congratulations poured in from all over
the world
Merkel is at the pinnacle of power in
Germany and in Europe a year ago she was
the object of harsh criticism Greek
newspapers dug up old stereotypes and
all over Europe old fears of Germany
re-emerged Germany the economic power
dictating austerity to others
it's all suddenly Europe is speaking
German the chancellors become the
dominant figure Germany southern
neighbors followed the parliamentary
elections wishing they could vote they
would like to see the Social Democrats
in power or at least junior partners in
a grand coalition to tone down Merkel's
demand for austerity the savings
measures don't help Greece we need
investments a kind of Marshall Plan and
it doesn't look like Shula and Merkel
have that in mind but which reports are
right about Germany's policy on the euro
a British magazine recommends unity
behind the Chancellor at least miracles
policies are known and stable and many
countries want miracles help taking
national competencies back from the
European Union the Germans and the
British have much closer are much closer
in their views of a lot of other things
for example how free the economist
should the economy should be how much
state involvement would there be and I
think the Brits and other people as well
including Angela Merkel see a multipolar
Europe emerging where it's not just
France and Germany driving the
integration forward British applause for
America is new earlier all she received
from them was scorned Merkel style of
politics was to take things slowly she
was persistent
and gradually she gently forced her
course upon her partners thereby
fulfilling expectations of Germany
the world needs the strong leadership a
strong leadership role that comes out of
Germany today Merkel has her
difficulties with the role of leader
it's a German dilemma how can the
Chancellor lead without dominating the
rest of Europe how can it use its
economic power without isolating itself
from its European partners if Germany
representing all the European countries
promises something that is not possible
because the markets are attacking then
Europe's flank is completely exposed in
her new term shall have to tell the
Germans that rescuing the Euro will cost
even more that will make her popular in
the rest of the EU seeing Merkel comes
people if Europeans fear Germany it's
because of German history not Germany
today she faked any fide docent hurts it
and miracle is a common personality you
can't be afraid of her on a personal
level Gaby that's why I think that
precisely in an era when Germany is
strong again Angela Merkel is the right
kind of person to have go to 2pi go to
personally cut
deep inside political tensions are still
at work
anger and hate are not extinguished and
Germany's leading role in Europe has not
yet matured but miracle knows that
Germany is the driving force of European
unification and must not back down